what's with the jeans welcome to your
mom's house yeah it is your mom's house
your mama's here and we're at her house
house welcome back to your mom's house
it's been a while we've been very
irresponsible mommies yeah sometimes
mommies leave their kids alone and they
let them kind of do what they want to do
just eat hot dogs off the ground and get
weird and we we've neglected the podcast
I have to admit it's it's been busy so
Tom's been what have you been doing I've
been doing a lot we just need to get on
a more regular schedule right now do you
know I need to stop think we need to
stop being pussies you know what though
seas are strong now Posey to make babies
you let your pussy get loose I'm gonna
have some people that you know that what
do you mean like I'll just like I'll go
to like a store and like I'll be in
there like at the grocery store and
they'll be like a lady in line behind me
or something
and I'll just turn to her and I'll go
hey you ever you ever just let your
pussy get loose and and what's the
response been so far sometimes they'll
be like what yeah or they'll get really
angry but I'll say I don't mean like
physically asked what do you mean by
does does your pussy get loose that
means do you ever really have fun you
ever really enjoy yourself do you ever
do you ever let yourself have a good
time well if to respond to your question
yeah my pussy gets loose a lot I like to
have fun I like to eat pastrami I like
to let loose - yes - right yeah she Oh
nuts
all the peas yeah I feel like that
I just turned the mic a song we were
singing a song the intro song that we
did for you first okay I'll be honest
I've been slightly I was slightly and I
was working on something I'm not allowed
to get into details on it's very secret
it's very secretive actually the only
reason I'm Dean fuck's sake
the only reason I'm being weird about it
is you know like when you work on
something and you just haven't got it's
not hasn't been cleared I didn't get the
full yes clearance so it's right just to
be out of respect to show business to
show business class mm-hmm you got
queefs yeah
it's show business no business etiquette
I can't get into details even though
like I'm sure wouldn't be the end of the
world but I was writing on a pilot
that's as far as I can go that's
industry talk Tom oh yeah okay
everybody's in show business that's true
it's very important when when people
come up with ideas for shows they go to
a network and they go I have an idea for
a show and then Never Knows Network goes
what is it and then you say it's about
guys on unicycles and they throw hot
dogs and Donuts I like it at signs and
then these kids come and they have to
sing we wait but where are the
explosions
that's where wait wait till the second
act is the start of the first art show
it's just so exciting already and then
in the second act we set dynamite up and
there's a lot of fires men kids drinking
milk but as they're singing I need to
know who's going to be the next American
singer there's gonna there's singing
going on okay and the third act so you
have your kids you got your excitement
of the unicycles you got a big sight
what about Cougars by their Cougars
older women that are attracted to
younger men hmm that's the fourth is the
ultimate TV show yes yes old run
explosion bigger jump its american
cougar explosions yes it's a very good
combination
and then the executive goes No yes it's
working
Oh psyche opposite day you just psych me
out so hard Tommy I was so afraid we had
to start over again I really hated that
because we had such a good stuff right
now okay so now and then the executive
goes here you go 1 million dollars yes
here's a big dollars to make what is
called a pilot and right now you're
thinking well pilots fly planes what do
you mean yeah well in in the
entertainment Gervaise a pilot is the
one episode the show that you get to say
here's what the show would be yeah the
pilot and then based on that you you put
that together and then the network gets
to see your version like the actual no
seriously this is what the show would
look like great then they go no yeah and
then they crush your dreams and then
it's back to Starbucks you're a barista
that's kind of the thing that is so I
was working on a pilot for a few weeks
it's top secret you know let's just say
Steve Harvey may or may not but anyway
what Steve Army's book think like a lady
lead with your teeth lead with your
teeth we're dumb suits
I think his books called lead with your
teeth so anyways the and and you know
you sometimes there's a downtime like
when you you write your stuff you write
your jobs you can't be creative 24/7 no
I mean I don't people think you can be
and you just can't and you also have
sometimes you actually literally finish
everything you've been asked to do and
you go what do I do now and they go you
have to wait till we get notes yeah
notes are fun right notes will come
before you go to sleep meaning do them
executives send you really cool things
like we don't like the word read put in
the word Burgundy yeah and then you go
by the red rhyme with the other word
that you want to rhyme with well make
something round with burgundy like
slogan D mm-hmm
so anyways in that time you know a lot
of a lot of perusing elegant
good word that's a really good word yeah
perusing you never used that word a lot
of perusing the web
yeah and anyways I would became
fascinated with this Twitter or name
slash mean she's very she's dark and
very smart and clever very pussy centric
very pussy centric and really funny yeah
like and I was telling somebody else
about it how you know the more you do
comedy and you you try you do different
things with in comedy you realize that
some people are super skilled at certain
things you know what I mean like you
like sometimes you'll be like like
there's hosting like hosting a live show
I mean yeah right and that becomes your
like so and so is a really good host
like they're just really good at doing
that yes then some people become you
know or just are great comics or
whatever then you find that like you do
some people are great writers and great
actors and anyways the more you do the
more skills right no but you also figure
out oh I'm better at this than I am at
this like I'm not so good at doing this
but I am good at racing and I think that
I think most people would agree that
like tweeting is actually like being
funny in a hundred and forty characters
is a skill right like it's like a haiku
of sorts this Twitter haiku and you have
to be good at brevity and some people
that are really funny aren't really that
great at yeah tweets it was not very
funny list or or they're crazy or
they're totally you know I don't know I
didn't really is mentally ill well I had
a feeling that as well there's a number
of people like that are comics it like I
don't find myself to be a particularly
great Twitter or Twitter River I don't I
don't think I think you're great timing
on your way I think you're fantastic
you're my wife I know but I I feel like
I have like like every once in a while
be like that's pretty funny and you know
it'll get retweeted or whatever here
like that was a good one but I'm not
like I'm also not you know super focused
on it a lot of times they're taking my
dumps whenever anyways all of this yeah
I always want to tweet about shitting
it's all I tweet I don't I know I feel
like that's the only cuz here's a
two things I do daily I eat and then I
shit by the way I want to damn really
good you're sweet no but not do this on
but can I tell you why I think you've
been really good at it oh my god I'm so
embarrassed right now
well I didn't tell me I can no but this
is why you've been getting really good
at and then I'll get back to the I'm
sorry reason you've been getting really
good at it is because you are just doing
like honest thoughts yeah that's true
you know I mean like you're just like a
we went through them lately like their
jobs like and they've been very funny
because they've been very honest this
takes me back to /li sorry / Larry
seriously she's great she's fucking
fantastic
I don't know what else if she does any
other comedy things but if she were to
be judged just on his grades / lean your
tremendous and I told her I did some
research because I get obsessed with
people yeah I googled her and she has a
great tumblr account and she's like this
game yeah I'm the one he sounded Oh grow
up I'm the one before you did okay but
Tom okay I just talked about it because
she's so cute and she has its homework
yeah but she's like a twenty-something
year old students so you're asking what
is she she's a student right and she
wants to be a writer I know this you
know what you just said you I just meant
that I don't know if it's currently
actively doing it I'm so excited that I
know she motherfucker yeah I can't
believe you're taking credit okay so
anyway no you're taking kuretake the
credit because I did yeah yeah so her
Twitter account which is very funny it
led me to her a tumblr rate which I
started to go through and it's really
great when you find somebody who when
someone's account like their page their
website or their tumblr account like
they did the research to be entertaining
for you like they found great and her
tumblr account is actually really fun
because she found great videos infinitum
one day while I was working while
working I was on her tumblr account and
I I found I went through the pages and I
found videos that I thought you would
love right oh yeah an email I was like
instead of sending you the link I just
actually pulled like four clips
things that essentially she had
highlighted I found like before I was
like you'll love these and I sent them
to you and like
one of them was a guy anal breaths
was one of them was a cool like
breakdancing those guys back dancing
yeah yeah one of them was really bizarre
guy doing interpretive dance with like
like chicken like really great there's
like then the one that like we've become
this is this whole long backstory of
slash moon is leading us to the other
video that was on her tumblr account
which was of a girl from Oakland named
creation creation K Rea right sty
backslash is number four I think it AR
EA less a WN creation you're right
creator and she's a total we grow from
oak town from Oakland for real like
she's like a 19 year old wigger girl and
she just she hangs out with all he's
like gnarly black dudes and she edits
their rap videos but her she has this
one video called bumpin bumpin bumpin
boba and bumpin bumpin has become the
soundtrack to her live the first that's
amazing it was viewed like I watched it
because it was on this tumblr account
yeah and then I sent it to you and then
I sat down I was like let's watch it
together yeah and then I knew that I
knew what your answer was gonna be like
when I found it which was like as soon
as her play you're like this is Brad its
ran yeah so rad you're totally into it
and then now when I hear them like fuck
what can I tell you about creation
because I've been obsessed with her and
I've been on her tumblr as well and
she's like a total we grow and she's a
lesbian which I always admire lesbians
because I think it's a woman if you if
you're immune to like male scrutiny you
know you don't have to be sexually
viable to men there was like so much
freedom in that like a woman is totally
free to be crazy and who she is and I
love she's got bamboo earrings at least
two pair and she's got like the crazy
hair and the eye makeup and and she's
got a bad attitude
and Naik it's all homemade stuff and
it's so entertaining and I would watch
her take a dump over listening to one
goddamn Lady Gaga song yeah this girl is
so much more interesting than any piece
of shit the music industry has right now
July Real Talk
she has a video of her sister getting
out of jail yeah and that's not it's not
for like an overnight like oh yeah in
the drunk tank it's like man those last
six months have been rough six six
months what do you think you're fucking
running red lights what do you get six
months in jail jail in prison no jail
she was in like the county jail
so what do you do six months for I mean
there's a number of things like you
could be I mean well you don't have any
money you can get locked up or longer
yeah obviously because you can't get
bailed out but you're not getting six
months for just like fucking jaywalking
like I mean it could be like a weapons
charge it could be a more serious
possession like a more serious drug
charge you know it's definitely a felony
why do I know do is like overnight yeah
yeah I mean it can be I mean it could be
like a fifth DUI or they're like you
seem to not let these really register
with you but like it's not solution I
don't think it's well creation if you're
listening we are so curious about you
and your sister I think her name is
vanity or beyond avionics ooh she's a
bad bitch and they're two bad bitches
and what is the charge I would love to
know why your sister I bet they're not
opposed to sharing with the charges I
mean I hope is that a faux pas to ask
people why there it is no sorry it's a
major faux pas but I didn't realize that
that's right but they deny it anyways
right when you're in prison everybody's
innocent oh yeah I got I got popped on
some bullshit they try to see babies
chick but then when they check the you
know it's like it was just mine prisons
amazing have you seen the new
scared-straight you've seen that oh holy
fuck mother you know what the thing is
though like it and it's hard to find the
there's an original there's an OG yeah
yeah her straight that they showed you
in like junior high right
but then MTV
revisited scared-straight they didn't
updated it yeah in the 90s that is
fucking amazing where was I
it aired and it's like I think it was
called scared straight again yeah scared
straight more scary shit your pants yeah
where I stood I remember there was a
black guy and there was like this white
kid and he was like they were pacing
and they were you know the the prisoners
were pacing in front of the kids
yeah let him sat down they would pace
and talk and one of the guys came up and
he was like put your thumb through my
belt loop and he made a kid come up and
put his thumb about and then he walked
and he was like if you were hey this is
what I make you do put your thumb I
thought little bitch and the kid was
crying
well once once with the thumb in the
belt like what does that mean if they
were in prison together he was saying
like you'd be my bitch Oh way then that
everybody would know that you're my
bitch is you put your thumb through my
belt loop don't walk around that's how
you go steady in prisons how that's but
that's letting everybody else know this
is my bitch yeah he was like you do my
laundry
except he wasn't talking like I'm
talking he was right it was really
intense and the kid was like it was at
the time it was definitely the funniest
thing I'd ever seen in my life
oh yeah well this one's pretty good well
first of all who doesn't know that
prison sucks and you shouldn't go there
15 year-olds that's who doesn't know and
these kids are all on the brink of just
one robbery away from going to prison
and I got to tell you if I were there
how long do you think you it how long
before you cry if you were in prison
like just personally in what school I
think I would I think I would cry a lot
yeah and often but if you show up and
cry negative fuck
real bad news you had to act yeah you're
somebody's bitch dude if you act like
you know for sure um I'm always I'm
always surprised how resourceful
prisoners are like have you ever seen
where they they like confiscate their
contraband or whatever is fucking they
they find like white lightning it's like
that crazy pronoun and the guy's like
well I stole some apples and I just I
made it under my toilet like toilet wine
that makes you blind and that guys
whittling like ships out of toothbrushes
you like motherfucker why aren't you
this resourceful in the outside world
like these guys are really crafty I feel
like we should put them to work and
other yeah like engineering yeah you're
smart people they're not dumb guys or
violent yeah but they're not dumb it's
amazing right totally
how would never do in prison cuz in
women's prison it's all like women with
facial tattoos who look like boys and
they all just want to like rape you I
think those girls are scarier than the
guys are Yeah right
absolutely terrible but they can't I
guess yeah cuz they they won't use your
girlfriend and stuff but they can't like
rape you rapey right because there's no
penises yeah but they can shove object
in there oh I think that's called it's a
temperature there's an actual term for
it no really there's an actual criminal
charge Oh penetration with a foreign
object I see no no no it's uh it's a
type of rape charge is known with an
object I forget um can I tell you
something by the way that I heard on Dan
Savage is podcast yeah Savage love I
don't keep her heard of me as like a
this really really awesome gay guy who
has a podcast about love and sex and
relationships and he talked about this
thing the other day called sounding mmm
have you ever heard of this where I'm
being sounding we're men or women they
put objects in their urethra like not
needles but like metal objects inside
their urethra
I guess men might do it to simulate
penetrate or to be penetrated yeah I've
done that anyway so you put something in
your pee hole and then you
debate that way Oh Oh another word thing
ever
oh that's just total cringe were that's
horrifying I know it's going on and you
can like permanently damaged or urethra
it's it's got to create scar tissue and
man you're gonna penetrate yourself can
you just leave it at your asshole I
agree put things in your ass and leave
it like a Christian and you just put
bigger things in your ass just go
through a series of objects that get
bigger yeah and leave your dick hole
alone leave your dick home alone your
dick hole doesn't deserve anything that
getting strapped into it have you ever
had don't they do that when they test
yeah things yeah but I never had that
test great thanks don't delay now yeah I
had all the blood work done but I never
had the dick swab yeah I heard about it
cuz I had a friend who went we were in
college one night he fucked a real pig
like hey dude I could smell her from
upstairs like yeah and then so we went
to the campus you know medical center
yeah and he came out I was like well you
get tested for and he was like this this
and that and then he's like that one
hurt so I was like hurts like don't you
just give blood he's like no they put
the q-tip in your dick hole and I was
like what the fuck did you just say I
had no idea they did that they stick it
in your dick hole yeah
earn it ah I know it makes me cringe
just a woman's vagina it smells mm-hmm
is that always does that always mean
there's like infection there or have you
just smelled women who just smell like
strong yeah I think they I don't know I
mean I actually don't know the answer
but I would think that it's it could be
just be a dirty couch but yeah so like
I'm saying it doesn't have to be
infected it's just just with a loud
shower yeah yeah cuz I mean you know
yeah getting it right they can get
sloppy and messy down there I wouldn't
know you know my vagina is immaculate I
know these nuts stink on a pretty
regular basis and they're not infected
yeah they're just dirty balls that's how
you're not staying daily son you do like
to keep them stanky yeah I think you're
more real when you have dirty
you can't let your balls you gotta let
your nothing to quote the ghetto boys
yeah but you got a little baby one time
who will Eadie
you see the midget no who's the mention
that you know which was Bill that's Bush
went bomb
yeah what is it the fifth Ward the ninth
ward in Texas no no the other from
Houston Jared let you not say thank that
nice cut those New Orleans why is it
called a ward that since that sounds
really depressing and you know oh you
don't want to move to a place called
can't they give them dignified names
yeah it's Willie D Bushwick bill in
Scarface I met the fucking third on the
tear yeah yeah yeah you want a lot of
rappers
that many yeah what about De La Soul you
had a little oh yeah friends low in
macei still are
yeah I've been talking a long time Craig
G with both met Craig G oh snap where's
London with that guy that dudes fucking
he's he's a VIP he's her life
yeah reals he's definitely OG can't tell
you I have one fantasy I don't have many
fantasies about celebrities I don't
really care I am a fantasy that one day
I meet Snoop Dogg they rails you and he
rails me no numbnuts like the whole
every table dogpound crew like tom
corrupt yeah yeah I'm gonna ride the
train that's why don't you just call the
black pie players Oh Justin player yeah
I just want you trail by like no
numbnuts every time I bring up a male
and I admire you assume that it's a the
same thing when I bring Wow if I say a
female you're always like you want to
fuck her
that is not like fuck I don't say fuck I
can't tell you my sneaked off usually so
I'm walking down the street and he comes
up to me and he goes what's up little
lady like what's up snoop and then be
like want us get you want to get high
I'm gonna smoke some weed and I'm black
alright snoop and then we get high
together but I don't get high with
anybody I usually just smoke pot along
yeah
that's what YouTube videos but I get
high Oh Snoop Dogg yeah that's right
enough of a cool fuckin thing to do but
I thought I would turn into like what
and then we went to fucking two pinks
and we got hot dogs I would do that yeah
yeah I could arrange for that you can't
arrange a Charlie Kim actually know what
your fantasy could have come true if you
would have fucking pulled over laid you
down the Bishop Don magic wand you
realize I was the key to your fucking
fantasies it was actually the bishop if
you don't have four million with this
there's the arch Bishop Don magic on is
one of the Marika's greatest pimps in
the history of pimping he's he's been
pimping since pimp is imposed and he was
an American pen marry the the one that
the the brother is directed well the
Hughes brothers I don't fucking
directors stupid dumb they're fucking
famous directors really yeah they made
menace to society
cheese barber
bang-bang-bang see great no black hole
so anyways Marion pimp is phenomenal and
it's got a lot of a lot of pimps but
pretty much even though they're all
pretty awesome like rosebud spelled to
demons for a double dose of that pimping
there's nobody like the bishop and
you've seen the bishop probably because
he he became like a mentor of sorts to
snoop
yeah and he's an old school he's in the
movie old school yeah yeah he is with
this new anyways that guy who looks like
a pimp in old school on stage that's a
real pimp but he's a retired pimp now
because the biggest pimp of all he said
yeah god biggest pimp of all called God
came down to me one day and was like man
you gotta stop doing what you've been
doing
you gotta go in another direction man
that's what guys movies and that's me
but the best is when he does the
calendar it's even celebrities and he
goes that's me and Dad
Trump and Donald Trump is like walking
through a lobby and then the bishops
heads like like that like they're not
it's not a picture with him that's you
in a room that Donald Trump was walking
yeah it's like that John Cusack movie
where he takes a picture of her in the
background it's fucking amazing but
still he's still a man and anyways the
Don moved out to LA years ago he drives
a green and gold Cadillac it's green and
gold because Green is for the money and
goal is for the harmonies yeah and one
day fucking Christina comes home and is
like Oh guess who tried to wave me down
today on the street I'm like I'm
thinking like it's gonna be like a
friend or something I don't know who
she's like the bishop what are you
talking about because I was driving down
Pico and I see that ridiculous car and
nobody has that car except the bishop
and I see him and I fucking lose my shit
cuz that's that's him and I like kind of
wave to him mistaken as pi about you'd
fucking those legs in that part no cuz I
was like excited like wait that's
exciting celebrities this is new
information that didn't snow you know I
mean like it's like seeing I'm one time
I saw Morrissey in the same way and I
was like oh my god you know I got a
Morrissey story how do you have a
Morrissey story okay so let me finish a
bit so the bishop you know thinks I'm
trying to bang him I guess and he's like
pullover polo and wants to give me his
card he holds up his business card and
I'm like I can't wear my I'm gonna pull
over on Pico so that the bishop can give
me his business all right like it just
didn't make sense I'm a grown a woman
you know what I mean yeah sure I got
time to mess with them people but it was
special and it was cool
hey hold up let me highlight you follow
you the bishop courted an acquaintance
of mine many years ago that's right
that's with a duty what is it t to
necessary
but anyway my friend was very beautiful
yeah and he showed up at her work one
time with his crazy ass ride in her
office and with two 6-inch Subway
sandwiches and was like hey yeah go girl
I'm taking care of my woman and she was
like oh this is my office
could you imagine the bishop walking in
here I'm sure the crazy pimp
yeah and that stupid outfit the stupid
outfit he was wearing - yeah he wears so
many clothes anyway so that you look
official like a referee with a whistle I
love him black people come up with
sayings like that it was like oh she's
never really good at things so good
that's so funny
wait what were you gonna talk about you
said the end another story SSO Morsy ah
yeah tell me man okay um so this weekend
I had a car service take me let's say
from the airport to the hotel yeah and
you know sometimes the guys are the guy
was really nice right so we're talking
in the car we have a little while drive
and he's like oh you know um I pick up
all the comedians whenever anybody start
like I know has met a lot of comics yeah
clubs or drivers I'll be like hey who's
a real asshole oh yeah I always ask that
and you know he was pretty much like you
know all the comedian's have been pretty
cool and I'm like oh I have you worked
with like other entertainers he's like
oh yeah like a lot of a lot of artists
and I was like musical artists and he
was like yeah like our company picks up
a lot of them for this area because I
was in Florida and I was like oh do any
of them suck and he was like oh yeah
he was like summer really cool he
actually said Madonna was he had Madonna
kind of a big deal right he was like
jerky tits he said that she was um
business you know she was like real
business yeah but but but like decent
yeah like not a fucking asshole that's
that's surprising because you think
Madonna would be a real coup chair about
then he said I mean Hootie and the
Blowfish fuck yeah but he said they were
very standoffish and by the third day
that they're hugging him oh because I
think you become the normal scene alone
let's face it - is that who the who
cares about Hootie in the blue that's
true history and those guys need a
friend wherever they can get one but
those motherfuckers
I don't know if that's just but here are
the two worst she said the two fucking
biggest pieces of shit are a there's a
Mexican singer named paulina Rubio and
she's a you know like Shakira like she's
this hot little fucking Latin
firecracker yeah whoo like you drive her
to the show and then the manager says
all right like you know you wait you
wait backstage cause sooner she gets off
you walk right to the truck when she
gets off stage everybody was in the
hallway is not allowed to look at her I
love that don't you love that
he says if she comes down the hallway
and they and you know like you weren't
expecting to see her but she's in the
hallway turn and face the wall oh boy
and I was like that's fucking horrifying
I don't know someone else has it like a
Tonight Show guy has that that's a nice
no is it Leno or Carson you gotta be you
know I swear to god I just heard this
night I mean it's killing me that I
can't remember which late-night guy yeah
I know
not Lenna then maybe Carson had a policy
that you couldn't look at him no Johnny
Carson yeah no you're gonna say Carson
Daly I'm like yeah of course yeah that
guy's a real prick yeah no but I'm
serious I forget where I was listening
well he said that and I was like that is
amazing that that but that's not end of
it yeah so they said if she walks down
the hall like will tell you if she's
coming but if for some reason they
didn't get to you in time and you see
her don't not only don't look at her
turn away look at the wall or look at
the ground get the fuck out huh then
because then she's ready to go go out to
the car
and when you open the door for her open
the door for her but don't look at her
look away how do you not look at
somebody it says said so you look away
yeah
then when you're driving keep your hands
at 10 and 2 at all times so she can see
both your hands on the wheel and don't
look at her in the rearview mirror oh
boy like this list of this like the
worst I was like that sounds like the
fucking not only but the most amazing
part of that is who gives a fuck about
paulina Rubio
yeah she's like a Mexican superstar you
know she's like Selena goes where are
all the tacos do you think that's all
Mexican singers sing about I know they
do I speak Spanish so we'll see you song
for me York you know nice tacos tacos
cool kiss concerns known this done
Tapatio apathy apathy ome girls that
have not done that did okay see now is
that policies like that usually come
about because so many people like I'm
just trying to think in her mind is it
because so many people were looking at
her well we discussed it with my the
driver and I after he said that I was
like that's fucking horrifying but then
we came to the conclusion of that policy
has to be in place because of something
in other words everybody's now paying
the price for something that horrible
yes
somebody proud didn't just offend her
but probably in some way violated her
you know personal space or something and
so they put up this but it's still a
shitty fucking policy yeah like I'm sure
somebody I don't know if somebody
grabbed her or did something but in
order to limit that she's a fucking
asshole to everybody that's super sad
that's a bummer the person is Morrissey
oh nothing much
almost left Morrissey on the side of the
road no yeah did he do said that he was
all right oh no he was like that guy
where's he from
Morrissey English she's English he said
he's uh the drivers really nice and like
he was very well-spoken yeah and then he
goes uh he's like yeah he's he's back
there on the phone and he's like fuck
you motherfucker like yelling into his
phone and he's my driver was doing like
this sort of off British idea you know
he was like fuck it oh fuck you what the
fuck dude fuckin fuckin he was like I've
never anybody talked to anybody like
that before
who's he time business managers and all
kinds of people just screaming and he
said you know he he just was he didn't
like him because of that but then the
day he was supposed to leave
he's driving Morrissey at the airport
and as they're pulling in the airport
he's getting phone calls that there's
technical problems on his plane because
he was a private jet and they're like
this and that it's like it's not ready
to go well he was fuming at that and
then to the driver he was like what the
fuck are you doing here what are you
gonna sit here all day for two fucking
hours like get me the fuck out of here
and he was looking where you me to take
you he's like fucking anywhere and he
started screaming at him so much that he
was like I was ready to just quit the
job right like I was just gonna pull
over the side of the road throw it in
park and get out of the car but he
didn't but he was just he absolutely
says he's the worst fucking person that
I mean everyone's experience is
different but Morrissey to not defend
Morrissey has been known to be you know
he's an uppity prick basically that's
his persona and usually you find that
people's personas aren't very far off
from the person yeah it's very seldom
you know is somebody playing a bitch or
a dick very well and they're not
in real life so well that you know hi
fuck Morrissey yeah so that was just
from a very kind
South Florida driver crazy here's what
else is there
well we talked about that fuckin woman
there was yesterday
yesterday I flew again I got in and we
decided to have right and we decided
that well we can't yeah but I arrived
yesterday we decided to have lunches
together yes and so just a mommy lunch
we sat we said on like was it oh yeah
so where you could you sat on the like
the front what's it called
yeah let's sidewalk patio kind of place
and we're sitting there and it's really
busy like sober likes really busy on
Sundays yeah it was Mexican gays it was
it was so cute so we sat there and we
noticed you know we walked to this place
but there were there was a car an SUV
there was parked with its tail in the
crosswalk that you crossed the street
with and the rest of the car was in the
red so in other words the the entire
vehicle was parked illegally but it was
in the red and then the very tail of it
was in the crosswalk so it was like fuck
the parking rules
fuck people walking yeah fuck everybody
yeah I so then you see that and you go
like who's this fucking asshole well I
shouldn't emergency me like she's got me
if so if it's a woman maybe there was a
baby that's dying normal I said it was
gonna be
well here's the thing was that sorry I'm
eating Toblerone live this we took bets
on what kind of douchebag parts it was a
very expensive yacht with a Lexus SUV
and the fucking red zone in front of
Trader Joe's on a Sunday is it a let's
say a nepeta white gay guy
a Silverlight guy is it be a white woman
with blond hair and ugg boots or see
none of the above like it's those two
those are your options and of course it
was conference plugs an uppity cunt
a typical you know entitled bitch on her
blackberry and her ugh boots and taking
her time it was a burly stroll she
walked out of one store the store that
was basically next to where we were
eating she walked up to her SUV oh and
she had a bag that she had just bought
stuff she put the bag in the Lexus yeah
and then shut the door and you're like
what an asshole
you should she just excuse me
parked there so she can get that shit
only from them instead of getting in her
car she went over to another store yeah
where she's proceeded to shop and cheese
store for but she went to the grocery
store yeah for 30 minutes yeah came out
got back in her car fucked with her
phone yeah then left and we were just
like what do you do well we were
debating cuz I was I thought you were
about to yell I was gonna lose my shit
yeah well especially when I see that
it's not an emergency and especially
when people park either in the red zone
or in handicap zones when they're you
know it's not an emergency and you're
not handicapped
go fuck yourself yeah and I was about to
yell at her because I do believe
handicap is completely anything that's
fuckin your piece of shit yeah yes this
this is the kind of thing where you're
like I don't know it really it bothered
me to where it kind of got my blood
pumping away to fuck do you think you
are well and here's the thing too is
that that bitch went oh it's a $500
ticket I don't care yeah worth $500 or
whatever the field is we park in the red
zone so I don't have to go into the
parking lot which is two feet away right
so I get my cheese juice which I don't
eat because I weigh 90 pounds but what
should the punishment be
for people who do that realistically she
should get stoned she fucking beat her
there really that's the kind of person
actually when I see people like that I
go that person has never had their ass
kicked and even though I don't I mean I
just I do feel like when you see someone
like that you go you motherfucker yeah
it would really it would humble you I
wish somebody would just kick your well
sometimes me I think then it shows
riding a truck would never have a you
don't care money is no object
but getting her ass beat by another
blonde like me yeah what if it's okay if
you're a woman and you see another woman
doing something shitty to challenge her
to like a fistfight that's right I'm
like look bitch I'm gonna fuck you up no
but it really just did really I really I
just it's crazy how many people in this
world think that they're fucking special
you know yeah and and the really the
reality is you're not special no but it
drives me bonkers when people think the
rules don't apply to them
yeah but you think she's special she is
entitlement she thinks she's special in
that and it's totally white time it's a
classist oh this fish isn't this bitch
has been told her whole life how special
she is and she has money to back it up
and to fuck like you know she made it
dangerous for people walking driving
people couldn't see out of that parking
lot and they turned on the road because
her car's fucking block and everything
you're just a fucking it and you know
what I know that this nothing will come
of this and this is just you know
venting for the sake of it but just some
people really fucking suck man and and
it's just it feels good to say how much
they suck yeah of course
I really fuck it I hate that woman with
everything inside of me and the one
thing that I wish we would have done we
talked about was run into Trader Joe's
real quick and grab like six eggs and
egg the car that would have been fun if
and if we had the cover of night I might
say why not why not do it you know I'm
30-something years old well what's gonna
happen
I had cash no no records no trace yeah
you know and also you'll notice when we
drive in Beverly Hills I was over on
that side of town that the people even
drive shittier like there is even
entitlement and how some people drive
well in there I just don't like that I
it really makes me mad you know our
friend yesterday was saying how he's
observed that a lot of people over here
are very friendly and so really yeah I
never really thought about that until he
pointed that out he was saying though I
don't know I don't think they're
friendly I I think you time out the hill
people like this man collectively I
think there are a lot of snobs over here
well yeah I mean but I mean it's
interesting I mean this is getting into
really la stuff but a lot of times as a
general label people think of like the
west side of town has like the uppity
snobby part of town because like the
west side is where the real money is but
there's a lot of fucking inside yeah but
I think cuz I'm a cultural east side
snob I will admit to that
like I'm wholeheartedly snob I am I'm a
cultural snob and that I you know I like
certain shit and I'm a bit yeah I am a
little bit of a hipster and but I think
it's different I think it's insecure
hipster is what that is it's not really
snobbery yeah it's more like insecurity
I'm really insecure and I don't know how
to be normal and cool so I'm gonna act
like I'm better than you oh but that's
all that is what are you doing I'm
looking at the timer oh are we talking
for 43 minutes oh my god that's so
ridiculous well time flies when you're
having fun with your mom so much fun
wait can I tell you my name Jason oh
yeah well we should say that MJ's is a
bar next door to this place it's not
just a bar well but I mean to give it
the career at the back yeah but the back
story deserves is that we've been
shopping at the trade of those in Silver
Lake for quite some time
yeah yeah four years and so the parking
lot at Trader Joe's is a fucking
madhouse and so they have a remote lot
that's just basically a hundred yards
north of it and when you park in the
remote lot on your way to
Trader Joe's you walk past a bar on the
MJ's and MJ's is where the boys get down
on the east side of town and you know we
didn't know what it was the first few
times then one time we saw a poster out
front that said there was just like a
couple of like shirtless guys hugging or
less what that is and then for a longer
after many more years we figured out you
know after that we figured out what it
was gay bar and it was always like you
would hear like yeah they party a party
hard you'd be like there's some fucking
there's some cocks getting chucked in
there and you know you then we would
park in the regular Trader Joe's lot and
they would say no MJ's parking and like
you knew who was some fucking popular
stuff and then much later actually I
think this year we saw that that there's
two what happens on Tuesdays there well
there's a poster outside that says
rimjob every fuckin Tuesday the poster
says rim jobs yes every fucking - oh and
then for for hot dancers one ugly one
which I'm not sure I understand what
that means
I probably code for like hey why don't
you tickle my balls oh yeah I don't know
what that means I don't know things but
anyway so
so anyways frigging interesting what we
never we never made it into to MJ's it's
you know it's sort of intimidating and
menacing well not only that I do feel as
a straight woman I have no place going
into a gay bar male gay bar really
unless there's a reason like right I
feel like shitty just be like hey what
are you guys doing in here it doesn't
seem appropriate I don't you know and as
a straight guy I feel weird
going there when you're in town what huh
you don't even mean well you're a bear I
would say in the gay world that you'd be
considered a bear I think yeah I'm not
old enough
didn't we just find nothing yeah my
friend guy told me that you have to be
over 40 years old
I don't know age aside you would make a
handsome bear and a great catch for
anything MJ was always a fun reference
for us that's something that just talk
about and then you and your gay friend
of yours
got in touch and said they need to get
together drink wackjob where do we go
and you said well I'm in Silver Lake you
know there's a gay bar over here called
MJ's and he goes every fucking dude know
he knew it he knew the slogan and then
so awesome got to go and I got so that's
what it was like so I got to go inside
of the MJ's cavern and see firsthand
Tommy
it was awesome first of all super nice
bartenders everybody into wait let's
send it up what kind of guy do you go
there so my friend guy so it is a
Tuesday there you go we go on its
Tuesday for rim job it is rim job night
but we go around happy hour so four
o'clock in the afternoon and Sun still
out when the bar opens hey
then it was kind of empty so we could
talk he and I have a lot of catching up
to do and the bartender is super sweet
now here's the thing they were setting
up for rim job when I was there so
they're bringing out a lot of chains a
lot of a lot of chain work there was a
poster of an eighth hole being spread
open of an asshole I guess to show you
what the rim job so it was a wait so
this is a poster that especially that
they hung up on Tuesday I don't know if
it's ever NYX I'm not been back since
what size posts are we talking about
just a regular you know wall poster and
it's it's just an asshole or you can see
that it's a man spreading his ask you
know you can see that I believe if I
recall correctly I I just kind of glass
I didn't want to stare but it I think it
was of a guy yeah just spreading his
butt cheeks open mm-hmm but you knew it
was a butt hole and he knew was a guy's
butt hole yeah it's so great and like I
know you know I'm no prude like I I grew
up going to bars and nightclubs when I
was young you know when I was 15 there
was this place called cinematic that was
like a bondage bar they played golf and
industrial music so we go and I remember
like people getting whipped and beaten
like in public and you know I'm no prude
to it but I like did I I
I don't know there was a bathroom stalls
or unisex bathrooms and they had a sign
on the bathroom stall that was like one
person at a time we know you know you're
at a good gay bar if that's yeah that's
like one time we we went together to a
place on Third Street to get a massage
we had never been to this place remember
it would they were like penny first and
we're like this is weird and then we had
like our separate changing rooms and
like in the men's room it was like no
fucking in like it was something like
you know there will be no sexual contact
between people waiting for massage I was
like what was good we have to make it
yeah that's not like it happened a few
times that was like it's such a
persistent problem great that we're
gonna try to let people know ahead of
time there's a policy that that's where
that's where you put that up in a place
where people are going there just for
that like in other words they're like
hey do you want to fuck somewhere that's
a good place to do it
yeah so we need to put up signs to tell
people not to do it but you know what
I've learned from listening to the
savage live podcast officer I love him
and I'm so I'm just fascinated with all
the stuff that's out there and I no idea
that people do things and is that I
guess these are safe havens for people
who have like secret desires and you
know different kinks and this and that
and that's that's where you go to meet
other people to do that kind of shit I
mean where else are you gonna find a guy
who's like cross-dressing latino boy you
know who's into sounding as he
masturbates or whatever like that's
where you go to find that stuff and it's
cute it's amusing we make fun but we
love I don't hate the gays we don't have
so you feel like you learn something
though at a job Hey see look at this
shit what Delta it's a flight yeah but
that's what happened yeah just to
everybody who knows fly direct when you
can because once they catch you in
Atlanta or any connecting city you're
fucked you just forget about it always
wise writes
I wanted to see it I thought you felt
like looking why wouldn't you obsessed
with this Twitter cuz I fucking felt
like it man ah bust my balls about
fucking work we're doing a podcast so um
so what oh my god unbelievable
you're unbelievable ah you know what I
you so much you don't hate me as much as
I hate you so anyways yeah is there
anything else you're gonna share but I'm
James I did well I mean look I I I was
afraid of it and they conquered it and I
liked it a lot and I would actually go
back and I liked it it exists there and
I'm happy for the gentleman who can go
in there and find out they're looking
for so yes it wasn't as scary the
thought of me but it was aggressive it
was aggressive I'm gay men are very
aggressive with each other well guys
were like that male sexuality is like
that right
speaking of love we did Valentine's Day
together mm-hmm
that was fun we went up to San Francisco
we did cobs Valentine's we did do cobs
together those fun that was a lot of fun
speaking of inconsiderate assholes like
that lady the part in the red there was
an inconsiderate couple that we thought
they got thrown out of that show it was
a very dramatic Valentine's Day funny
was the night before at the show we did
the night before Valentine's Day I was
talking those guys about I was like you
know I had a really bad Valentine show a
few years back really bad in the sense
that I was like there's a crazy group of
people and I told them you know I told
them about my being on stage and having
just like a a bad interaction when is
this when what went show Valentine's Day
years ago where Hartford and yeah yeah
like called lady Conte and like I hope
she got a AIDS really bad and um but she
was a real ass when I was like you know
there's just fuckin assholes that shows
and the next day was Valentine's Day yes
and it wasn't the same style this was
like this was actually the worst the
worst person ever at a show the worst
audience member
is not a heckler ever it's the people
that won't stop talking
that's the worst person at a show for me
yeah is somebody who is either so
oblivious or so self-centered so fucking
inconsiderate to other people that they
keep having conversations so they're
drunk and they're not aware that but
they're still doing especially when
they're in the front row front row and
like they were talking and then I like
you know a lot of times when like when
that happens I'll be like what are you
doing and I turned it into like a joke
and they thought it was great that I
turned them talking into and and that
kind of ended it and they basically
tuned in for like five minutes
like I I turned them talking into like a
joke I made fun of them but like kind of
like in a fun way
and then like I was like all right now
they're back on board five minutes later
they're sitting there looking at each
other and fully talking and I was like
hey you're talking again like what are
you talking about they're like you know
nothing and clearly they're drunk I know
they're drunk but then it happened again
and again then they got warned then I
asked him again like what the fuck are
you talking about and then finally like
the fifth time I was like you got to be
kidding me and I didn't actually say you
got to leave but they just came over and
threw them out they didn't they were
irate and they threw a fit which look if
you get kicked out of a comedy club
you've done something to offend the
comic or other people like you've earned
it because a lot of times comedy clubs
they don't want to throw you out believe
me they don't because then you're gonna
tell everybody you got kicked out of
that club you're not gonna come back and
you're gonna spread bad word and they
don't want to kick you out so listen if
you get kicked out of a comedy club
you've earned that shit oh yeah you
definitely have and suck it up and call
a cab and do not drive home well you're
probably drunk when I told like I
haven't told the audience that this
night was like you know as a comic I
never feel like the audience should be
obligated to laugh like you don't have
to think that the like what I'm saying
is funny you have more than the right to
not laughs but what you don't have the
right to do is not listen yeah you don't
have that right
oh don't be distracting don't fucking
talk like Tom get up and leave I'd
rather you say fuck you get up and leave
yeah then sit there and talk and I just
told him like the biggest piece is like
the biggest injustice to this woman and
this guy being there being asked like
that isn't even that they're not
listening to me and like not giving me
the attention that I want then it's that
they're ruining the show for everyone
around them yeah like there's other
people there are fucking show they don't
give a shit about whatever stupid
conversation you're having at the table
yes why do you why do they not get a
chance to listen to the show because you
have to fucking talk entitlement because
a reason you park in the red that's it
comes full circle every time yeah it
does you know it's just saying it's the
same asshole when you're at a movie and
they keep talking you're like hey
asshole could you stop fucking talking
so that I can watch the movie so in
consider these people that's it made me
so irate that they like there were
people to the left to the right and
behind them that every time they decided
to talk about their stupid lives and the
dumb thoughts that occupy there they're
fucking my new brain empty bullshit they
were ruining the show please these
people were out trying to have a good
time on the Valentine's Days of
Valentine's Day know what though I gotta
say that there I've never had a great
Valentine's Day show yes because it is
valentine bond with an M the the
expectations are so high and I don't
know what that is the audience maybe
brings that in that they're gonna get
late or this and that so maybe they're
more tentative about what you're saying
cuz they don't they want to get later on
you don't want to laugh it's something
that the dates not laughing at or
whatever it's garbage it sucks can I
tell you what else I mean my pet peeve
is now for people who fart on planes
next to you oh and once is okay because
I do it too with the consistent farting
did you have a bad one lately yeah I
came home from Toledo and somebody was
blasting gems all the entire way
like to don't don't gas me out like it's
not cool and it's not cool the whole
time I said I told you I said thanks to
a guy who did the whole he he opened his
legs and went up like his pelvic area of
my yeah he did like six in a row where I
was like I just looked at him I was like
no you watch him do it yeah I was
sitting right there and then I saw him I
could smell it and then I look at him
when I was like really
he didn't give a fuck he was like 65 and
was like this is what happens I drop my
dad's like 65 but not that old I didn't
say it was old as fuck I just thought he
was an older guy
so anyways let's move on oh my god oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah well that guy
it was I've smelled some fucking bombs
and I have to admit it is fun to fart on
a plane but at least like no what are
you do I I feel like that's considerate
did I do this
yeah instead of going like and making a
face and looking at the first thing like
that I will put my hat down tip my hat
down close my eyes fart but under the
guise of hey I'm asleep I'm not trying
to that's how you get out of it right
yes that's considerate right very least
you're not like you have to put some
theatrics some understated theatrics put
a little thought into sleeping reading
you read aren't farting that's right
people whether they're you know what I
can't do
I can't far without some type of mood
like I have to move it's very hard
unless the farts really primed to just
let her out sometimes you got it why
don't you lean I lean on my side yeah
that'll do it now you can do side only
on my left side for some reason when I
lay down on my left side I can fart I
like to farm more in first class
whenever I'm upgrading oh isn't that the
best yeah let those bitches smell what
silver likes
thing hey em so we gotta wrap this up
what do you got going on tell me what's
going on this week what up I'm gonna be
at crackers Indianapolis March 2nd
through 5th in Indianapolis at Broad
Ripple
nice come and see that it should be a
lot of fun it'll be really cool yes I
will be headlining headlining this lady
headliner come and see it
that'd be great go to crackers and which
one Broad Ripple love crackers comedy
com2 buy tickets and that's this
Wednesday this Wednesday through
Saturday nice yes I will go let's see
tomorrow Tuesday the 1st of March I will
go to Louisville Kentucky with one mr.
Joe Rogan and we'll do one show only
with him in Louisville on the 2nd and
then I fly to Salt Lake City on Friday
the 4th and I'm doing wise guys in Salt
Lake City and I believe the trolley
square location Friday and Saturday two
shows each night so if you're in Salt
Lake City or in the surrounding area
come see me at wise guys Friday and
Saturday the fourth and fifth and then
next week the two of us will be at go
bananas your bananas
Cincinnati's one of my favorite club
it's the best club ever yeah it's really
my favorite clubs in the world it's
fantastic and then that's yet so that's
next couple weeks we're doing crackers
and wiseguys and go bananas yeah the
best comedy names
ridiculousness every wins would just
really round that out that quartet so
that is all friends we will try to be
more consistent we'll definitely do one
so Cincinnati definitely for sure we
have to we have to make a schedule and
really stick to it I know sorry mommy
listeners I'm sorry I'm gonna put this
thing up right now all right we love you
love you tell your mama you love her too
mm-hmm